la parole est à monsieur premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre le monde titré hier armée
amputé france des classes et monsieur le
premier ministre quel paradoxe ce serait
d'engager l'armée française au mali et
en même temps de créer les conditions
budgétaires de son démantèlement ce que
la france fait aujourd'hui au sahel avec
courage et succès pourra-t-elle le faire
dans cinq ans on aura-t-elle les moyens
déjà avec les réformes de la
professionnalisation conduite par le
président chirac et de la
rationalisation budgétaire
l'armée a fortement contribué à
l'exigence de réformes de l'état
le ministère de la défense monsieur le
ministre le drian et sur le plan des
efforts budgétaires
largement plus vertueux que de nombreux
autres départements ministériels
les arbitrages présidentiels
quant au livre blanc et bientôt quant à
la loi de programmation militaire
2014-2019 sont toujours attendus à
l'initiative du président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense nationale notre collègue jean
louis carrère un large consensus s'est
affirmé au sénat pour demander un
plancher des ressources consacrées à la
défense fixé à 1 5% du pib' renoncer à
cette exigence reviendrait à renoncer à
notre souveraineté et à placer notre
sécurité sous le parapluie américain
pour de nombreux pays la croissance des
risques est parallèle à la croissance
des budgets militaires
renoncer à cette exigence reviendrait
aussi à renoncer aux grands programmes
de notre industrie de défense ce qui
nous condamnerait à une destruction
d'emplois dont le pays n'a pas besoin
monsieur le premier ministre
où en est le processus d'arbitrage quant
à l'avenir du budget de la ddt france et
pensez vous convaincre nos partenaires
européens que les pays qui par leur
défense participe à la sécurité de
l'union puissent sortir une part de
leurs investissements militaires du
calcul de leurs déficits budgétaires et
ainsi aménager la règle des 3%
souhaitons que dans l'avenir la presse
titre armé soutenu france défend tube
merci monsieur jean marc ayrault au
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin
vous imaginez bien que si le président
de la république a pris la décision
d'engager nos forces au mali ce n'est
pas pour demain nous empêcher de
poursuivre cette capacité d'engagement
au nom de la france mais même au delà de
la france car nous savons bien que dans
cette intervention qui a été approuvé
par tous les pays de l'afrique de
l'ouest par la communauté internationale
dans le cadre du respect du droit
international
ces demies c'est une mission que nous
engageons non seulement pour défendre
l'intégrité du mali pour défendre la
liberté et l'autonomie des pays de
l'afrique de l'ouest mais c'est aussi
une lutte sans merci contre le
terrorisme qui permet de défendre à la
fois les intérêts de la france de
l'europe et même au delà puisque mais ce
message est compris bien au-delà de
l'europe donc ce n'est pas ce que nous
sommes capables de faire aujourd'hui qui
devrait nous conduire à nous empêcher de
le faire demain et je conclurai s'ils
voulaient bien sûr cet engagement dans
quelques instants c'est pour ça que le
président de la république a engagé
un travail
qui est celui de la mise à jour du livre
blanc sur la défense et sur la sécu de
la sécurité nationale c'est un travail
considérable d'un grand intérêt et ce
livre blanc sera adoptée mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à la fin du mois
d'avril mais je souhaite que le
parlement puisse en débattre que ce soit
ici au sénat ou de l'assemblée nationale
avant l'été c'est en tout cas un
engagement que je prends devant vous
c'est la moindre des choses
ce livre blanc présentera les risques
les menaces auxquelles notre pays doit
faire face mais surtout analysera le
contexte géopolitique qui est le nôtre
et les types d'engagements auxquels nous
devons faire face il est bien évident
que nous devons continuer à défendre
l'intégrité territoriale de la france
vous avez parlé de souveraineté c'est la
base même de la défense nationale mais
c'est aussi la prise en compte de
risques nouveaux qui sont de plus en
plus lié les risques intérieurs les
risques extérieurs doivent être abordé
de la même façon en tout cas avec la
nécessaire cohérence si nous voulons
être efficaces le président de la
république l'a exprimé à plusieurs
reprises et je le redis devant le sénat
le modèle d'armée qui découlera de ces
travaux sera conforme aux ambitions de
la france
en europe et dans le monde c'est à dire
je lui rappelais protéger notre
territoire et la population française
préserver nos forces de dissuasion dans
ses deux composantes et assurer nos
capacités d'intervention seul ou avec
nos alliés ce modèle répondra également
aux nouveaux enjeux que nous devons
faire face notamment dans le domaine de
la cyber défense
nous avons d'importants progrès à faire
comme celui du renseignement comme celui
du transport stratégique ce n'est pas
bien sûr au moment nous engageons nos
forces en mali avec un professionnalisme
et un engagement que je veux à nouveau
saluer que nous allons baisser la garde
d'ailleurs je voudrais profiter de cet
instant pour remercier à nouveau tous
les groupes parlementaires de toutes les
sensibilités que j'ai reçu lundi avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
belize et la défense et ont empêché
représenter parce qu'il est très
important qu'en effet dans ces
circonstances la communauté nationale
proclame son rassemblement et son unité
ce que chacun a fait dans le respect de
ces différences politiques je tiens à
nouveau à le faire devant vous à vous
saluer et remercier au nom de la france
mais aussi au nom de nos soldats qui
sont aujourd'hui engagés dans une
mission particulièrement difficile et
dangereuse après l'adoption du livre
blanc iran la loi de programmation
militaire elle sera à cohérente avec le
modèle d'armée que je viens d'évoquer
elle préservera aussi et je comprends
votre préoccupation je la partage
l'excellence de notre industrie de
défense dont chacun mesure la nécessité
stratégique et la contribution au
dynamisme de notre économie
je vous le dis franchement j'ai parfois
été surpris y compris de titres de
journaux
cessons de nous faire peur avec des
scénarios catastrophes qui n'ont jamais
été sérieusement envisagée
en tout cas ni par le président de la
république ni par moi même ni le
ministre de la défense alors vous
évoquez un sujet complexe et celui d
intégration dans le calcul du déficit de
chaque pays des dépenses militaires
ne dis pas que c'est un faux problème je
dis simplement que dans ces
circonstances ça serait comme une
certaine forme de face à leeds facilité
en quelque sorte une échappatoire parra
propre à nos propres responsabilités en
tout cas là où vous mettez le doigt sur
une question qui est juste c'est la
question de la défense européenne qui
est ces dernières années a pris trop de
retard et qui doit être sur la la table
sur l'or de l'ordre du jour de l'union
européenne c'est d'ailleurs un sujet qui
a été évoquée récemment par le président
de la république lors d'une rencontre
qui a eu lieu à varsovie ne laissons pas
cette question deux côtés il n'est pas
juste que seuls deux grands pays la
grande bretagne et la france fait tant
d'efforts pour la défense pas seulement
de leur pays mais aussi au service de
l'europe
l'autonomie stratégique
dépend tout autant de notre modèle
d'armé mais aussi de notre capacité à
redresser nos finances publiques et sur
ce point vous avez évoqué les efforts
qui ont été faits par la défense
nationale nos armées depuis plusieurs
années et je le tiens effectivement à le
saluer mais cet effort de redressement
de nos finances publiques doit se
poursuivre et chaque ministère il
prendra sa part en tout cas
je vous dirais franchement monsieur le
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin
que je suis parfois
étonnés d'une certaine forme d'injustice
à l'égard du gouvernement quand on
critique nos intentions sans les
connaître alors que si on regarde la loi
de programmation militaire précédente à
peine votée elle a déjà été oublié donc
évitons les fausses querelles évitons
les excès ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui
c'est de bâtir le modèle d'armée de
demain cohérent avec le dresse le
redressement de notre pays et avec les
risques et les menaces auxquelles il
doit faire face je veux que s'instaure
sur ce sujet un dialogue serein entre
l'ensemble des forces politiques du pays
je sais monsieur le premier ministre en
pierre raffarin l'intérêt que vous
portez à ces questions et votre propos
vient de une nouvelle fois de le
rappeler mais je veux vous assurer que
nous partageons ce sujet la même
ambition comme je le dis à l'ensemble
des sénateurs est que la france est une
grande nation
elle continuera à jouer son rôle j'en
prends ici l'engagement ce que la france
fait au mali elle pourra le faire encore
dans cinq ans